- All right, y'all it's
time for my first guest.
She is a perfect example of
why you should never give up.
She's persevered through almost
a decade of rejection
in Hollywood and music,
now she's starring in
one of the biggest
shows on TV, This is Us.
And last year, a song she sang
was nominated for an Oscar.
This year, she releases her
first album of country music
and I cannot wait to hear it, I love her.
Let's all say hi to Chrissy Metz.
What's up Chrissy, how you doing?
- Good, how are you?
- I am so good. It's lovely to see you,
by the way you look beautiful,
I love you in a ponytail.
- Listen, thank you. I
got about two hairstyles.
It's up and sometimes straightened down.
(laughter)
- Here's mine, this is
mine when it doesn't work,
like I curled my hair this morning
and it just was like, what
the hell is happening?
So I just pin it back.
That's when I just pin it back a bit,
- You go.
- And I'm like, I went for this,
I didn't, I hate being here in makeup.
- Nobody would have known, not one person.
- Well, you're kind,
I understand you've been holding it down
in one of my favorite
cities, are you in Nashville?
- I am since the beginning of March, Yeah.
- Were you there like working
and then were just kind of were
like, okay, I'm stuck here.
- No, we came out to finish
the back half of my album.
- That's what I meant.
- Yeah. And then the record
just stopped literally.
And so, yeah, we've been here Donnie and I
have just been stuck, thank
goodness I have him here,
but we've been stuck.
- Oh my gosh. Right? Yeah, I wouldn't,
I know I have friends that
I sometimes get jealous of
when they're like at home
alone without children,
but for the most part,
I think for months that would have,
I would have gone insane.
I have to be around at least one human.
- Right!
- So, so it is you and your
best friend, Donnie, right?
That y'all been, y'all been
finding ways to stay busy.
- We've been trying.
- I need you to tell us about
these tetherball battles
and how much I love that
you're playing tetherball
'cause that's like my childhood.
- Right? Third grade I literally was like,
what can we do in the
confines of a backyard?
I got a regulation tetherball
folks is what I did
from the Internets.
I was like, Donnie, let's play,
well, he's not very versed on tetherball.
I am, however, and I'm
also super competitive,
which is obnoxious.
- Me too.
- Let's just say I had.
This pinky won't go all the way down.
I have jammed this pinky and I can't,
I don't know what's happened guys.
So, Donnie starts kicking the ball
and I'm starting to like, you know,
it got competitive and
got a little heated.
- I was the same way, but you know,
every kid that grew up,
not in like the richest neighborhood,
if you know what tetherball is.
(laughter)
- Right. Right.
- Cause that was like a
cheap thing to have on the
playground for all of us.
So I love tetherball,
I think it's amazing.
Well, congratulations on your
recent music deal, by the way.
That's really cool.
The first song you released
is called 'Talking to God'.
So what's that about?
- So that was found on Ashley
McBride writer's retreat.
- Oh he's great!
- And I knew, I knew all the
writers on the retreat and I,
my manager was like, Oh, you know,
they wrote the song
this week and I'm like,
I want to hear it, and I
just fell in love with it.
It was one of those songs
where I didn't write,
I didn't have any, any sort of, you know,
time spent on the song, but I just was.
- Connected.
- Yeah, it just, it
felt so important to me.
And I get it that like, you
know, we all make decisions
or wish we would have
made different decisions,
and we all think about people
who aren't in our lives anymore.
And you know, it just resonated with me.
So I was like, I want to cut it.
Could I please.
- And I mean,
we've touched on this a
little in the past with you,
but isn't it true
that you didn't want to sing as a child?
Like you wanted to be in a band?
- Well, no, no. I wanted to sing,
that's what I wanted to do.
I really wanted to sing,
but I was too afraid of my own shadow.
And because my mom couldn't
afford an instrument
and all the cool kids were in band.
I was, Oh, I guess I'll join
choir because it's free.
- Girl, that's me.
(laughter)
- Right. I'm like, okay.
Right, and so it felt really
comfortable to be one of many,
but still like, understand
like the blending
and the technique and all that stuff.
And that was really
super fun and important
and that's really where I got, I mean,
I've always had a love for
music cause I grew up with it,
but actually doing it,
and the safety of a
choir was the beginning.
- Yeah, and I always love like growing up
in a choir as well, in that surrounding,
and I was too poor to play.
I couldn't be in band either,
cause we didn't have
money, and this was free.
So I get you. I feel you there,
honestly, being in that
choir, being in those,
around those personalities
of kids that were,
we were all just oddballs.
Like we were very nerdy.
Like, you know, none of
us were cool and we just,
we're just figuring out
our own personalities.
I think that really helps.
So I, I love that you,
you love to sing and you were like, well,
I just didn't want to
be in the spotlight yet.
So knowing that is amazing
too about yourself.
So Chrissy, the five most
recent episodes of This Is Us
start streaming on Peacock
TV today, which is awesome
'cause all these streaming services
are really bringing new life to shows.
So are y'all excited about that?
- Yeah, absolutely. I think, you know,
a lot of people don't
necessarily have the time
or didn't have the time
and now they have the time
or have the ability to even access it.
You're right though,
there is so many people
in this world that haven't seen it,
even though it's an international show
- Exactly!
- And if you can make things
convenient for people,
I think they're more inclined to watch it
and then they're like hooked.
Cause it's just such a real raw, you know.
- I just find it interesting.
I'm excited about the peacock thing
because this brings new
life to all these show
that like could make a
really big impact on people
that just didn't know
they were even ever going
to get to see it.
- Right.
- So, so how, how have you been keeping up
speaking of This Is Us, do y'all have,
I know that you get in these casts,
especially these really success ones,
y'all are on there for seasons,
like have you all been
able to catch up at all?
Have y'all zoomed at all or done anything.
- Yes, we have done the
zoom, we have zoom zammed.
And it was so sweet because Justin Hartley
who plays Kevin, he's the one that's like,
Hey guys, do you want
to Zoom? And we're like,
(laughter)
- I love that.
- And that's just Justin,
he's not just a handsome
guy who's super talented,
he has the biggest heart.
And so it was so cute that he was the one
that wanted to arrange it.
So, and then Chris arranged, you know,
the actual appointment
time and called it the
"Miguel Rivas Fan Club", which
Jon Huertas plays Miguel.
And everyone was always
like, no one likes Miguel,
Jon is the best sport about it all,
because everybody just
makes a joke about it.
But yeah, it's a lot of fun.
We just get to sort of see
each other, which is nice.
It's like the phone
calls aren't quite enough
and the text chats.
- No, getting to see each other
like any kind of zoom
or FaceTime or I agree.
I mean, can you imagine what
this would be like without it,
without seeing people like
in a, just on a phone,
you know, in the kitchen
with the Roseanne phone line,
that's like 10 feet long.
Yeah, that would kill me.
- Yeah. It wouldn't be
good, that's for sure.
So grateful for technology.
- Yeah. No, no, me too.
So who of your, This Is
Us cast seem to be having
the best time in quarantine.
Like when y'all talked, who's
like living their best life.
- I think really me, honestly.
(laughs)
I have to be honest, I
really like being at home.
I really do.
- You don't have kids right now,
so that's, there you go, that's why.
You know what, I'm telling you that you're
having the best time.
I don't know about
everybody else, but that's.
I love, I love actually
getting to have the time,
especially like, you know,
recently I've been waking up every morning
and coloring with them
and it's like a lot of,
kind of me time with
them and I've loved that.
But at the same time, it's like,
Oh my gosh, I really want to
go to a dinner with adults
and just talk about adult thing.
- Right, Right.
I mean, I feel for
Sterling cause he and Ryan,
he and his wife, are, you know,
obviously teaching their
two sons and he's like,
man, I got to run guys.
I got, I gotta start a class.
I gotta do this, we gotta do that.
- Oh my gosh.
- I know I don't, I don't listen.
I can barely keep a succulent alive
that I started having in
the beginning of quarantine.
- Succulents are like the
easiest plants to keep alive.
- They don't need anything!
- That's amazing,
that's why you're my
favorite human. Alright.
Well there's something else that
I thought was kind of
cool that you're doing.
So you have, it's a new
line at Walmart, right?
A new clothing line.
(overlapping chatter)
You know that's a huge brand!
- I know, you know, it's funny.
I was, when I was home,
I drove by the Walmart that my mom
and I had to like walk to
because my mom's car didn't work,
and it was super far.
I mean it felt like 10 miles,
I think it was only four, but regardless
I was like, Oh my gosh,
I have this partnership
with a brand that I've been,
you know, literally shopping at forever,
but when I was a young kid,
a chubby little girl,
like they didn't have cute clothes.
There weren't cute girl clothes
for chubby girls or for anybody
that was sort of outside
of the straight size,
just generally.
And now that they're
incorporating such incredible,
it's like affordable,
but it's also trendy.
And I think that's really important
cause I think when we feel good,
we do good and all of that,
it's all sort of encompassing.
And so when I, you know,
was even approached by, by Walmart,
I was like, Oh, well, yeah.
This makes sense for me
because it's something
that I think is just.
- I think it's real.
That's what I like. It's believable.
It's like I'm the same girl,
I shopped there too growing up.
It's, I think, you know,
for some people they hear like,
Oh, well you don't need to be trendy.
Like that's not important,
you don't realize how important that is
unless you don't fit in that circle.
- Right.
- You don't realize how
devastating that is for a kid to like,
even me, I grew up, you know,
with Payless shoes and
everybody else had Nike's
and it was like,
my shoes were the ones
that made black marks
all over the basketball court and it's,
and those kinds of things count.
And that really does, you know,
you start recognizing your life
and your being is like less than.
And so I think that it's really important
and awesome that they reached out to you
because you represent a lot
of the American community
and the world community,
and so I think it's really
important that when you,
when any of us do like
these sponsor things
or these endorsements or these deals
that it's believable and it's real,
and that's what I really loved about it,
so thank you for doing it. It's cool.
- I'm super grateful.
And it's funny how, you know,
life happens and how
it all kind of folded.
I'm like, Oh, I would never have thought,
you know, a girl struggling
in Gainesville, Florida
would, have sort of a really
important partnership with.
- Yeah. And, can create such an impact
for other little girls in Gainesville
that are going through the same thing.
- Right!
- So I think that's the coolest thing
we're able to do with whatever
you want to call this,
our little version of super power.
So, but thank you so much, Chrissy.
I always love talking to you,
I'm so happy you're in Nashville,
it's such a fun city and y'all,
Chrissy's new single
'Talking to God' is out now
and expect more music from her this year.
I'm very excited about hearing it
and remember to check out her stylish,
affordable clothing for
plus size women at Walmart.